during the course of a meeting the  longer the meeting continues without you  having said anything the harder it will  be for you to not suddenly after the  meeting is already one hour in to only  now start talking and start saying  something for the very first time so  this barrier of silence is building up  over time the longer the meeting gets  which is why your typical recommendation  is that you should try in the very  beginning just at the start of the  meeting to say something interact with  someone just drop a couple of comments  couple of remarks even if maybe they are  not the most valuable ones ever but if  you do this then this barrier this  perceived harder for you to talk again  engage again will feel much lower